I mean looking at it from a public
safety standpoint and like the regulator
is having to make sure that the public
is safe and making sure that you know
the state of California is being
responsible for this massive billion
dollar industry that's how they felt it
was best to regulate it right so Dubai
for kata into these like these slices if
you will and then really have oversight
over each in different each individual
section so they are able to really track
the entire production line
from seed all the way up to consumer so
those extra little things that I'm
adding essentially give me extra point
yeah
so then that way it's not just okay we
have a security company in fine check
the box it's really being thoughtful
about how you can be efficient or
mindful or a good community leader but
in a way that's presented to cannabis
businesses or at least a lot of them in
Northern California are upheld to the
standard where we have to give back it's
like part of the business as part of our
agreement with the city that we have to
give a percentage of River profits or
donate a certain amount of time to the
communities so that's something that
cannabis companies are adhered to that
are are great and other and really other
companies should be a hell to that same
standard what regulation has done is
basically forced this almost impossible
standard on growers to not use it like
harmful pesticides and have all of these
nasty things toxins that used to be
regularly found in cannabis if you took
raspberries from Whole Foods and put it
under the same microscope and held it to
the same standards as cannabis it would
not last but knowing that our industry
now has developed methods of growing at
mass production scale that can pass our
super strict testing regulations that's
a huge win and that was a win because of
government and that was a win because of
the regulators children like especially
three-year-olds their face glitter their
eyes twinkle because they don't
understand stress
understand time they don't understand
deadlines and there they just Sparkle
and it is the most beautiful hopeful
happy thing in the world
someone's opinion me contradict yours
where's my friend Allen it's all about
your perspective who are we in what is
the nature of this reality what's up
everyone welcome to simulation I'm your
host Allen sake on we're on-site at the
beautiful new West Summit the cannabis
tech conference we are now going to be
speaking with Sawa Ibrahim Allen nice to
meet you for coming on the show really
appreciate very excited for this me too
super pumped Sawa's background super
interesting has been a Copiah near in
the California cannabis industry opened
and operated numerous dispensaries and
cultivation extraction facilities
totally worth 50 million in sales
annually through multiple states yeah oh
my goodness okay so and also first came
to dispensary to do an IPO that's
correct
plant touching yep yeah okay so let's
talk about this what have you been up to
this is obviously really hard to know
how to do this with the regulatory
frameworks that are constantly changing
so yeah how have you been handling that
and what are you up to now making things
maybe a little bit more efficient and
those processes teach us about this
process well it's funny from a certain
standpoint I'm lucky because I've been
doing it for so long way I got in the
industry in 2008 and back then reading
the regulations was pretty simple
because there really weren't any and so
so far the rules you know a challenge
presented its own set of challenges but
when working with the city of Oakland
and then it what ended up being the
state of California and just forming
those regulations I got I come out on a
rolling start so you know back in those
days you got a dispensary permit well
that was the only permit type of permit
that existed so it allows you to do
everything
that license so you were able to
cultivate extract essentially distribute
transport there was a myriad of
different platitudes that you gain with
that one permit so in that sense I
learned a lot of the industry just
because of the lack of regulations and
we I happen to have a dispensary permit
and then once California came on in prop
64 passed and they started having all
these different types of license
categories you know we just did our due
diligence and like watch the process and
became involved once you know
regulations wouldn't necessarily suit
any cannabis business and kind of helped
reform to make it more viable whoa so
interesting so like the codes get
updated over time and then that directly
affects all of the different components
of the industry in in in different ways
and it's it's important that they make
the processes less friction 'full more
friction less and more able to be
efficient and creative and do the
medicinal benefits and the textile
benefits and all these other things
that's correct yeah the the the the
regulations as it stands today
definitely has a process like
everything's bifurcated so like for
instance you can you have a distribution
license but you can't move it without a
transport license and once it's an auto
transport license then you go into
retail then you need a retail license or
so on and so forth so voice inside every
practically yeah and then there's a lot
of procedures especially for extraction
and for and for edible making for
instance like those are several
different licenses so to make your
edibles like the oils that go into your
edibles and depending on your process
that could be one to two different types
of license and then to infuse your
edibles as a different license and then
to package your edibles is a different
license and then to move your edibles to
retail as a different license this seems
extremely bureaucratic at the same time
although it's for safety as well of
course but
seems heavily bureaucratic and in a
sense making it yes difficult for
something that used to be just growing
easy growing out of the ground and us to
be able to leverage for whatever purpose
is one and now is yeah I mean there's
definitely I mean looking at it from a
public safety standpoint and like the
regulator is having to make sure that
the public is safe and making sure that
you know the state of California is
being responsible for this massive
billion dollar industry that's how they
felt it was best to regulate it right so
to bifurcate it into these like these
slices if you will and then really have
oversight over each and different each
individual section so they are able to
really track the entire production line
from seed all the way up to consumer so
from that standpoint I understand it
from the public safety standpoint and to
be quite honest with you at that time
when prop 64 passed the industry was
asking for that like we wanted to be
taxed we wanted to be regulated because
we wanted to understand where we stood
so we can talk to investors we can get
additional banking and funding and and
invest in our businesses without having
the risk that the city would shut you
down or you wouldn't be able to get your
your whatever it's like expand your
business so in that sense it was kind of
it was it was the middle ground yes yes
okay so both opening up more for
adventure investment and financial
contribution to actually happen to
accelerate put some fuel into the fire
of the industry but also not make it
overly bureaucratic where it's hard to
actually like if you need a license for
every single one of these tiny little
steps and can make it maybe a little bit
more complicated overly complicated so
it's interesting to see how then those
the most optimal code gets written and
like different countries have different
codes and so do you do you feel like
where was the I which which market did
it that I blew my pee oh so bloom rolled
up to tear tech on the OT
cqx OTCQX that's correct so it's the
closest you can get to the Nasdaq
without being on the now second but it's
oh it's over-the-counter essentially
penny stocks which a lot of the market
has is living on that exchange because
Nasdaq has these requirements that quite
frankly like nobody can really qualify
for okay and obviously everyone's wink
waiting for banking reform interesting
okay so then what what OTCQX what makes
them able to like IPO cannabis stuff but
you know like what is written in their
codes that enables that on that
particular exchange I wish I knew the
details to be able to articulate it to
your audience but unfortunately I'm that
I'm an operator I'm a cumulus girl that
everything I do know about IPOs and the
stock market and taking your company
public I basically learned by living
through it yeah so just being forced to
take these take the knowledge from the
attorneys as I was going through my deal
but my understanding of the OTC is is
kind of like buy it at your own risk
type of investments like in the sense
that like you know they're not like you
could buy a lot of different types of
companies stock on that exchange yeah
but once you move over to the Nasdaq
there's so many different requirements
that qualify a company to be on there
you have to have keep trading on a
certain dollar price a certain volume
you have to abide by certain regulations
and these much stricter standards to be
on that exchange and it's all kind of
about safety in that sense is you take a
risk like you said on a like an OTCQX
versus like a Nasdaq interesting then
maybe that is the combinatorial
permutations that can be run is you have
maybe like a state like Colorado or
Washington or telephone
that have their own little different
regulations packages that people have to
follow and then we see what is the best
and people get to like move with their
feet into the ones that they want to
well I think that it's interesting
because obviously like the state of
California when they were starting to to
put their process together they went and
looked at Colorado Nevada there's a live
scene a lot of the the process and the
procedures and security measures and
things like that cookie cutter Dover
from Nevada and they went out and they
kind of did their research and their
homework of like what worked what didn't
work and this is what they came up with
now I don't necessarily think that this
state of California is unwilling to
amend I think that we can work together
as an industry and as a regulatory body
to work together to amend the policies
to actually make sense for the business
it makes sense for for all of just
making it more efficient an example that
I have is we just did so Highland events
was the first company to basically buy
I'm sorry sell cannabis at a major
mainstream music festival that wasn't
once right that's correct
outside lands that wasn't on a County
fairground and so that was a very
intricate process getting with all of
the brands as product in and being able
to sell it however there is this one law
in our policy that says that I need to
have all of the staff who's going to be
working at the event their names and
their shifts planned 72 hours before the
event and then submit it to the state
right and I can't add names so come
Friday everyone's like oh like they're
everyone's grinding but Saturday people
don't show up on time they don't show up
at all I'm short-staffed I
to infill I can't add more staff so
there's these like little person there's
these little policies that I think are
easy to change and that were that I
believe the state would be willing to
hear us and listen to why they don't
necessarily work and we would work with
them to alleviate any of their concerns
but it just some of them don't
necessarily make sense in practice yeah
this one is really interesting like so
many of us have been to the bigger
festivals and to have like little
cannabis experiences at those festivals
is really important for people to safely
and also in a very curated way be able
to experience their their augmented
states that they want to or taken at
these cool events and so like when you
say something like Saturday someone
might not be showing up that I had a
register 72 hours before him like to me
it seems like okay well we can create an
such process of such efficacy where you
can literally in even within a
government even within a regulation
where you can just submit something as
simple as a license you know of this
person and an ID and then just for that
to be immediately and put it scanned
vetted whatnot and then just to give you
that simple check mark back here's their
ID for the event not like this we our
processes have a little bit of ways to
go but I yeah I like I like where you're
like you vote you're how do you do that
like if you did say something like that
where do you even go in like this to
deal with a state like an augmenting
process or like when you were talking
about all the another thing you were
just mentioning was this copy and paste
in different states like part of that
also we've been talking about in the
valley for a while has just been
companies just copy and pasting they're
like data standards or whatever from
different companies are taking the
incorporation standards and it just what
it does is it also just makes everything
homogenous and it ran then trying new
creative combinations that could
potentially work yeah so what are you
it's about stuff like that I mean as far
as like sorry it was my thoughts on
specifically like copy and pasting
policy or HD like how do you change okay
yeah let's do both of those exactly okay
so I would say that in order for anybody
to like have changed the best way to do
it is particularly in cannabis because
that's the only example I have but like
the way we've been successful is by
working with your local government first
so for us when we went to with outside
lands using that as the example we would
work with the city of San Francisco be
like oh look this is where we were
short-staffed us one day and this could
have been way more efficient and we
would have been out on time Wow can we
have your support on trying to amend
this one thing and then you get their
buy-in and then when they're having
conversations with you know the
regulatory body in Sanford's arms are in
the state of California obviously like
their opinion means a lot to the state
so they can help advocate for the same
thing that you're advocating for because
it's efficient and it makes more sense
and it's again about Public Safety and
if you're short-staffed in an event like
that that's not okay
right so who is the person with in San
Francisco that you would talk to that
would then talk at the state level
Marisa so shoes she basically is the the
head of the office of cannabis okay so
so mostly sophisticated exactly most
municipalities either have their own
cannabis department right now or in
Oakland for instance it goes through the
city administrator's office so if if
it's an event you might do city
administrator's office depending on what
body regulates what portion of the
business that you're trying it could be
special activities if it's a retail if
it's you know so on and so forth so
having having buy-in from your local
government to then help advocate from
that side now on the other side you want
to advocate for yourself so there's two
ways that question before you to have
care self where would the sit so then
the city rep talks to at the state level
who do they work with at the state level
usually do we know so for in this
particular instance would it would be
basically the the bureau of cannabis
control so the Bureau of
that's actually like a border or
representing yeah so Laurie Ajax runs
the bureau and Alexis Podesta they
basically are run everything cannabis in
the state of California the interesting
so she show you the San Francisco or the
LA wraps work with these the state yeah
perhaps and then they then amend the
codes which then make it easier for you
to do the things like that they they
could so what we would end up doing it's
usually not that easy and it usually
takes a very long time and it the best
approach is to hit it from multiple
sides so that's just so you've got one
side there right other side so the other
side is you have to advocate for
yourself and there's basically two ways
of doing that one the state holds a lot
of meetings where they want to hear from
the public they want to hear from the
businesses they want to know what works
and what doesn't work
attend the meetings join like go talk
female like inquire that participation
is absolutely key
so participating then if you have the
means to do so having a lobbyist or
somebody that's in Sacramento that's
there basically full time to be able to
like mmm to advocate for these changes
you've got the money
because that's a lot full time lobbies
expansive full time lobbies very
expensive and and if some people can do
and some people can't like for the
amendments that I would like to see
changed they help everyone across the
board I can't just be like oh only
Highland gets this one you know it's if
we advocate for these simple changes
there the benefit of the entire industry
and all of the different companies
therefore could be crowd funded then
from multiple parties into that Lobby
correct so so could be and then you have
to be very organized to do that or you
can find people who have like-minded
interests so just using this as an
example we have Emerald cup we have high
times we have all of these other chalice
we have all of these other main huge
festivals that would benefit from a
participant just to use it as an example
yeah yeah oh cool cool and then also
would like the the Coachella's in law
loses all these other places as well
when they also want to get their own
cannabis experience is happening there
they'll also benefit from it
I like this I like this I like this a
lot like kind of like pulling in time
money resources into updating the codes
that then get the benefits get
distributed democratize to the masses
exactly and then if you if your
companies can't afford a lobbyist like
leaning on them and their lobbying team
and their legal team and then just
showing them like hey you know I'm not
sure if you ran into this issue how do
you account for it or whatever and then
maybe they maybe it's not an issue for
them and they can teach you something
that is beneficial that you don't you
don't have to face that issue again you
know let's let's do an interesting
thought experiment here with we're
talking about like this copy and paste
issue that sometimes happens where
everyone just becomes homogenized
and the way that they do something and
it kind of it can inhibit creativity
from actually happening if you were to
maybe like let's say press reset and be
able to like play in solid land and you
know we will all have our designer
worlds in our virtual augmented
experiences and it'll be very
interesting in the future let's say you
can take us to Sowell in you have this
magic wand you get to set the the
frameworks for how even just the small
community could get to you know
experience or a town let's say or
however much size with minutes again
scale so matter here but how would you
see things being frictionless but safe
and efficient what kind of pieces would
you put together to let you know like
free market forces go at play but
so safely yeah it's hard it's that's a
tough one to answer I mean if I had a
magic wand I would just like make
everybody play nice and like we don't
need a lot of oversight because we just
don't need it but early on nice plain
nice there's people not playing nice no
I just mean in in business it's like
everybody does what they say they're
gonna do and so you don't need contracts
and whatever this is in la-la land right
as I were talking about and in to bring
it sort of more into reality one
proposition 19 came before proposition
64 and proposition 19 basically proposed
that the government's the state of
California given local control to each
different city and county to create
their own laws and their own processes
which becomes a little difficult when
you are planning an event or doing
something in a different County and
because you have a whole different set
of laws and to abide by which is
happening now but ultimately what that
would have done is is allow cities to
create their own different license types
so for instance the City of Oakland
could just have one edible license type
and that's it and it takes you from end
to end for edibles or extraction and you
can have any type of volatile solvent or
whatever solvent list extraction methods
I think just simplifying the processes
will just open up naturally the ability
for other people to get in and compete
yeah but yeah and what would it an ideal
like simplify process look like to you
process gosh I've been in cannabis for
so long it's never been simple mm-hmm
it's I mean at least from my standpoint
like I responded in my first RFP when I
was like 24 25 years old are you again
yeah so a request for proposal so
typically how these have a lot of
licenses work there's there's two types
of licenses that you can get now I'm
gonna shift over to retail let's just do
use retail - there's ones like in the
city of San Francisco where they're kind
of land
you space so it's more about the real
estate in the community and making sure
you're in a good neighborhood and your
neighbors not mad that you're there
you're not your school exactly you have
to be a certain about a thousand feet
from a school or anything that caters to
children all these different things and
it's it's not as competitive as
something like Oakland where when
Oakland was first doing their processes
it was they would release a request for
Proposal is called an RFP and it's
basically like a book report in school
where you have to like respond to all of
these questions and you put it together
in a report and then they grade them and
based on the ranking and how everybody
scores against each other then they
allocate a certain amount of licenses
like to the top tier book reports on how
you were to operate your dispenser
exactly I've competed a municipality
that made you do multiple RFPs
so for instance they like they'll
release the first one the top three top
five get invited to do the second one
you get another RFP after responding the
second one and then you have to do a
public hearing and you have to do a
public like presentation and hold
community meetings and then you get your
license and then maybe gets filters for
more of the cream of the crop was right
exactly exactly but you know I kind of
like that process a little bit more I've
done well in that process I don't think
that I would have I just for some reason
like that works really well with me I'm
a competitive person and I used that I
was like drive to to take it on and plus
with the deadlines it kind of forces you
to be on a specific track versus a
land-use one it's like the landlord and
maybe and sometimes and it just becomes
it could become a very expensive
drawn-out thing but yeah so I've always
ended up competing for all of my permits
on a local level yeah well what an
interesting way to also potentially
filter for some of the best proposals
like ideas for
like well well what could maybe some of
the best things that you proposed of
some of the best things the other teams
have been proposing across different
counties and cities states etc could
those best ideas be added into the ideal
style of running yeah definitely I think
after a while I think in the beginning
because when you compete in a process
like that your application becomes
public record and people can request it
right so after a handful of these went
out a lot of the competitors requested
everybody's information and then so you
go to the next town and you're like wait
a minute they use that that's mine but
there's that sense that yes it's it's
kind of like the best of I think where
it gets interesting as far as innovation
is concerned is more on when you're
grading and when they're grading these
applications that are typically grading
them on a curve they have no idea what
the a is until everyone they've read on
through everybody's thing but what that
forces you to do is to really take your
time and try to like capture all of the
thoughts and all of the benefits to the
community in each particular section so
for instance with security let's high
level so security you're like okay this
is my security plan this is what
standard this is what the state wants
this is what the community wants
whatever but what how do I make this
even better okay I will offer up any
data to the police department if if they
ever need it or I will have access to
them that they can just log in and see
our exterior cameras or I will hold
community meetings on security once a
month for the neighbors to come in and
see if and report anything or just be
able to share their concerns so those
extra little things that I'm adding
essentially give me extra points yeah so
then that way it's not just okay we have
a security company it's fine to check
the box it's really being thoughtful
about how you can be efficient or
mindful or a good community leader but
in a way that's presented to a
Municipality mm-hmm I like that yeah
efficient mindful good community leader
rather than just checking the box I
think that's some really actually
beautiful ethic that can maybe also be
brought to other industries that are
crowing so one one thing that I would
say is that so
in cannabis and this is where we're in a
unique is particularly in Northern
California
it would stemmed from the medical
cannabis movement right which always had
a layer of compassion so the first RFPs
that came out always had a community
benefits section and portion of it
because we were expected to give a
certain amount to people who couldn't
afford it people who were truly sick
people who were truly needy and so the
RFP reflected that they're like ok well
what are you gonna do for these people
but the first RFPs that came out also
got cookie cutter done a lot of
different municipalities so cannabis
businesses or at least a lot of them in
Northern California are upheld to the
standard where we have to give back it's
like part of the business it's part of
our agreement with the city that we have
to give a percentage of River profits or
donate a certain amount of time to the
communities so that's something that
cannabis companies are adhere to that
are are great and other and really other
companies should be a held to that same
standard yeah did you reside in a
community that has other people living
in it and businesses in it and how do
you become a good community member and
with good morals and ethics and and yeah
and share the fruits especially if like
high tech like those are some big fruits
that could be better shared also
inclusive stake holding all different
types of cool stuff it also seems like
going from like the indigenous days of
just like having crops and versus like
now having governments that regulate the
way that I use that which just seems
like a massively different like
lifestyle just a human like with their
land and their different crops and
in farms I advocate for people to be
able to grow their own cannabis like
people should have the right to grow
their own cannabis for themselves and in
their family period like I'm a big
believer in proponent of that so in that
sense I feel like you can still stay
connected to the plant however just to
go on the flip side what regulation has
done is basically forced this almost
impossible standard on growers to not
use like harmful pesticides and have all
of these nasty things toxins that used
to be regularly found in cannabis and
because of regulation we now like most
all of the all of the cannabis they all
pass they don't have any of these yucky
things in them anymore so it's kind of
nice in the sense that if you took
raspberries from Whole Foods and put it
under the same microscope and held it to
the same standards as cannabis it would
not pass but knowing that our industry
now has developed methods of growing at
mass production scale that can pass our
super strict testing regulations that's
a huge win and that was a win because of
government and that was a win because of
the regulators whoa yeah that's such an
interesting way to view it it's like
when can regulation actually increase
the safety of something that millions of
people are actually using around the
world yeah when it first kicked in I
heard so many girls be like it will
never happen we can't do this we have to
use these things guess you don't yeah
that's yeah that that's kind of stuffs
really interesting I like that going a
lot okay two quick questions that we
asked our guests on the way out are we
in a simulation oh my gosh I bet you
know what
think I am I really do think I am
because my whatever thing I'm in right
now it's like I don't know I mean it's
manifesting or maybe it's just really
like the law of attraction but the
simulation I'm in right now it's like I
am just any enter - anytime you put the
severe amount of energy towards
something and ends up happening and I
kind of dig it but it's also a little
weird I'm like god this is probably a
simulation yes okay and then what do you
think is the most beautiful thing in the
world my daughter tell us why she hurt
like children like especially
three-year-olds their face glitter their
eyes twinkle because they don't
understand stress
they don't understand time they don't
understand deadlines and there they just
Sparkle and it is the most beautiful
hopeful happy thing in the world and
they got mama nurturing them and they
don't got a quills for rent and food no
not yeah everything is just happy mama
play with me okay we adults I want to
just recruit people hey play with me
like adults and like you start like
playing with little like discs or
dancing I mean that's when we all have
the most fun I mean that's why we
started at Highland events right like
for me I loved partying and I love to
get people together and I love to like
host things I like the fanfare of it all
but then I also love cannabis so it was
just perfect
yeah so this has been such a fun
conversation thank you really we really
appreciate thanks everyone for tuning in
we would love to hear your thoughts in
the comments below on the episode let us
know what you're thinking also check out
the links in the bible itís always work
also check out the links in the bible o
- new west summit support the artists
the entrepreneurs the organization's the
leaders around your communities that you
believe and you can support simulation
as well our links are in the bio below
and go and build
sure everyone manifest newer dreams into
the world we love you very much thanks
for tuning in we'll see you soon it's a
wrap good job good job
proud of us that was rockin awesome I
know I was learning from you
[Music]
you
[Music]